bout du travail sens de l'effort ou
encore persévérance voilà ce que les
élèves de l'école de la seconde chance
vont apprendre grâce au coaching de l'ex
championne d'europe de natation
synchronisée
muriel hermine spécialiste du coaching
en entreprise depuis la fin de sa
carrière
l'ex nageuse souhaite soutenir les
jeunes en difficulté moi je les
questionne parce que je considère qu'ils
ont les réponses aux questions qu'ils se
posent et aux difficultés qu'ils
rencontrent j'ai pas les solutions mais
eux en les solutions les amener à
prendre conscience de certaines choses à
regarder d'autres choses différemment
sous un autre angle et finalement ouvrir
des fenêtres dans leur tête et c'est des
moments émotionnels des moments
j'utilise des outils de coaching et de
formation qui sont vraiment très
intéressant et très très pointue et pour
permettre à ces jeunes de se dépasser
douze adolescents partent pendant deux
jours et nuits dans la ville de
fondettes dans le centre de la france
là ils seront encadrés par une équipe de
cinq personnes qui les pousseront lors
d'activités sportives comme de l'
escalade ou encore de la natation
une expérience qui a déjà porté ses
fruits lors d'une session test en
décembre 2016 les jeunes qui ont connu
un début de vie souvent compliqué qui
ont besoin de cette deuxième chance
reprennent confiance et
ceux qui sont revenus de ce premier
stage mais de la même manière ceux qui
avaient assisté aussi à la première
conférence et ont puisé une très très
grande énergie et c'est pour ça que ce
qu'on signe aujourd'hui sont le signe de
manière tout à fait sereine et à l'issue
des deux jours l'association de muriel
hermine accompagne financièrement les
jeunes en les soutenant dans la mise en
place d'un projet professionnel
pour cette première saison 4 sessions de
coaching sont prévues entre janvier et
juin 2017